hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll one of the fascinating things
about biological organisms is their
capacity for self-repair
organisms are much better at fixing
themselves healing right than robots are
machines at least as we currently build
them you might have a self-cleaning oven
but if you break the oven it's not going
to fix itself okay but we all know that
we can get a cut a wound even break a
leg and heal ourselves but also this
healing has its limits right if we
amputate a limb we're not going to grow
it back so
where do those limits come from and how
can we manipulate them to get better at
doing things that we couldn't have
imagined doing before today's guest lea
gontoro is a biology professor at
caltech and she studies the form of
animals as they develop so similar a
little bit to michael levin who we had
on the podcast a while back
somehow in ways that we don't fully
understand the genome the dna of
biological organisms has a plan for how
the grown-up animal is supposed to look
okay
and how that actually gets manifest over
the course of development is very
interesting and something we're trying
to learn about so what leia's lab was
actually studying was what happens to
jellyfish when they lose a limb
jellyfish have a certain symmetry like
you might have an eight armed jellyfish
and usually if you just amputate a limb
they will not grow it back they will
sort of rearrange the other limbs to
maintain some symmetry so they'll forget
that the old limb was there but what
they found in the course of this
exploration was
sometimes the jellyfish would grow a
limb back it would just go back to being
an eight limb jellyfish again so
scientifically of course when does that
happen what are the conditions and
fascinatingly what they found is that
they don't need to really coax the
jellyfish into regrowing a limb they
just need to provide it the right
environment and the right nutrition
right the right chemicals around it
the
cells of the jellyfish know what they're
supposed to look like and so of course
once they found that they extend it to
other animals and fascinatingly it still
works they did it with fruit flies
drosophila right model biological
organisms and even with mice you know
just a little bit just like a little
finger of a mouse
but they found they could coax the mouse
into regrowing its fingers leah will go
into the details about this as i always
like to emphasize i'm not a biologist
here but the fascinating prospect is
that we do have within all of us the
capacity for not just knowing what kind
of limb we want to regrow but actually
biologically doing it if we're just put
in the right circumstances it's a long
way to go before we're talking about
doing this to human beings but it's not
completely crazy talk and that would be
a true game changer in a lot of ways
this is still very much at the stage of
very basic science it's nowhere near
being practical medicine but it's a
little peak at the frontiers of what
science and biology are able to do let's
give you an occasional reminder that
here on mindscape we have a webpage
preposterousuniverse.compodcast
where you can find show notes links so
i'll give you for example the link to
leia's group's most recent paper
including her students and so forth and
also we have full transcripts for every
episode and they're all searchable so
you can search all the transcripts for
mindscape almost 200 actually over 200
episodes now if you include
specials and amas and things like that
so a treasure trove of cool stuff that
you can find on the website preposterous
universe.com podcast and with that let's
go
[Music]
podcast thank you for having me we're
going to be talking about kind of
provocative big ideas right about
regenerating limbs this sounds very
science fictiony but i know that you do
a lot of different things in your lab
and i know that i think i get the
impression that this particular work
stemmed from previous work with
jellyfish you seem to really like
jellyfish and experimenting on them so
maybe we could just sort of start softly
by saying what what is it about the
jellyfish that got you so interested in
thinking about that as a model organism
well to be honest it was a
little side project in the left
in the beginning
i came to caltech and then i i
think i was
introduced to the research that john de
beery did
was doing on jellyfish and that got me
interested in just
thinking about jellyfish
for me it's it's a a couple of things
one is just the evolutionary position of
jellyfish enables us to make
evolutionary ask evolutionary questions
and the other thing is every model
every animal
has a unique
biology
that
can give us new insights
so with just studying more and more
different animals i believe we can get
more diverse and complete picture of
biology
it's interesting to me because i'm
totally not a biologist i'm sure i'm
going to end up saying several times
during this podcast i am not a biologist
and ask very elementary questions but
i'm interested both in the fact that you
know animals and plants and other life
forms are so different but they're also
similar they do share things they did a
whole podcast recently uh with eric
kirschenbaum about
uh the his idea that aliens won't be
that different from us because they're
still biological organisms and they'll
still have to solve the same problems
but one of the papers i like that you
wrote was about the fact that jellyfish
sleep even though they don't have brains
right like
it it is sort of a
thought-provoking idea that even
something as simple as a jellyfish has
to go to sleep sometimes
yes yes and this is i have to mention um
uh the students who really
pushed this project michael abrams and
then uh
claire bedbrooks and ravina and they
really
it was it was actually a very
fun
project and very fun the way it started
because it was really the students who
made the observation
and then designed the experiments and
then pretty much just told the three of
us vianna paul and me
that
they're going to do this project
and what did we learn from that why is
it the jellyfish sleep anyway
well we don't know why
although my colleague elliot likes to uh
speculate whether they dream ah okay
good if they sleep
but uh
that
really uh
i guess the the finding that they sleep
means that sleep
could be an ancestral property of
animals all animals sleep
and that raises new questions about
what sleep
does right
in animals without a brain
what does it even mean in animals
without a brain i mean i think of sleep
is sort of turning my brain off and
letting my body recuperate but if i
didn't have a brain do i just stop
moving
exactly so uh
that suggests that sleep may have very
ancient properties
that even just primitive nervous systems
um
sleep
or show sleep behavior
so jelly
yeah a jellyfish has a nervous system
but not a brain
exactly okay yes
got it and is it still floating in the
water when it's sleeping or does it go
to the ground does it does it take a nap
on the bed
in the species that we studied it uh
it stays on the ground well the species
is is stationary it does not float so
but what happens is that when it
sleeps
and it sleeps at night
it pulses less frequently okay
and probably this has some sort of
regenerative function of some sort right
catching up
repairing itself
yes
um
we don't know exactly what
this is a great insight for the audience
into how science goes like sometimes you
just discover something cool and you
don't know why or what function it has
but uh leave that for the next
generation right
yes and in particular my student michael
abrams is continuing studying this
process in jellyfish okay very good
and i guess
tell me how that led into the study of
what happens when jellyfish lose a limb
of some kind because
there was an original study you did
about symmetrization which is itself
interesting even before we get into
regeneration
right so i think the study on
symmetrization is is
what led us to
eventually studying regeneration
so that was again it started as a side
project
and we
made an accidental observations that
when we cut
when we injured jellyfish
instead of regrowing body parts
which was what we expected from
cnidarians
the jelly simply
rapidly reorganize existing body parts
and regain body symmetry
and this occurred really fast in two or
three days
so how many legs does one of these
jellyfish have
a jellyfish typically
has eight
legs okay arms appendages
they're really swimming appendages
and you by mistake cut one off or or
intentionally cut one off and
what how did by mistake you heard the
appendage
yeah obviously we don't by mistake cut
them off
and this was this was michael's uh
rotation project and what we did was we
just wanted to get comfortable
culturing them in the lab and michael
had a fun experiment uh decided to do a
fun experiment and did amputations just
to get used to handling them okay
and then two or three days later he
observed that ah
they it's symmetric become symmetrical
again
so
because we don't have the pictures to
show the audience right it's an audio
only podcast so you have eight
appendages and they're symmetrically
dispersed around the jellyfish and you
cut one off and sort of it squeezes the
other ones or redistributes its seven
so that those seven are now
symmetrically distributed yeah
yes yes you described it really well and
it works with any number of arms cut off
so you can cut two you can cut three or
four
half the animal and
each
cut part
reorganize within two or three days and
become symmetrical again
and
i mean
this is a very very unfair question but
why does that happen
do we know why again
it's hard to answer why
but
the way in biology the way we answer why
is to just observe what it does
so the animals that
regain body symmetry
regain propulsion
and that allows them to
feed to eat
i see animals yes so they these
jellyfish use their appendages to zip
around under water and if they were
if they were asymmetrically distributed
they'd just be spiraling away instead of
going in the straight line they want to
go in
exactly
okay
and and yet uh but so that does kind of
make sense even if we don't know sort of
the complete story there but then you
also discovered apparently this was just
serendipitous but tell me if i'm wrong
again
sometimes the jellyfish did regrow or at
least partly regrow an appendage
right so
in the course of just amputating
hundreds and hundreds of these animals
to study the
the process of a symmetry recovery we
start noticing that in very few animals
there's a little buds
growing from the
amputated site so
that
made us wonder
if
even though we don't normally see them
regrow their appendages if they may have
a latent ability
to regrow appendages so yeah so it's
it's
was it predictable like what kind of
circumstances under which they would
regrow versus symmetrize
right that was the long journey yeah
okay
well let's
yeah in fact in fact let me let me unask
that question let me ask it later
because uh
we're at the position where we say okay
um
under the right circumstances whatever
they may be the jellyfish will regrow a
limb so we need to fill in the
background about animals regrowing limbs
or you know other other kinds of species
regrowing limbs what's the state of the
art you know more general biology about
regenerating lost appendages is that
something for which there's some kind of
systematic theory or at least uh little
bits of knowledge
right so i think we're at an exciting
place right now where
the framework is emerging i believe
of how to think of that question
so that's the big question which is that
if you look
if you look at all animals around us we
know there's this few animals that can
regrow
missing body parts spectacularly well
axolotl is a good example of that
they can regrow lymph
the spinal cord what is that what is
that animal
salamanders okay
physicists or axolotls
right
but yes salamanders and axolotls
can we grow limb
this certain um kind of flat worms
called planarians can we grow missing
head or missing tail that's very
important and hydra
that's right anhydrous
which is a close cousin of jellyfish
can regrow any lost body parts
so some animals seem to be able to
spectacularly
regrow lost body parts
but
the rest of us are not as lucky
and what's weird about that collection
you just went through is that it's not
like they're all closely related to each
other
that's right that's right
so then the question is that when we
look at animals that cannot regenerate
is it because they
never evolved the ability
to do so
or could it be some biologists are
beginning to think that maybe all of us
can regenerate it's just that in some of
us the ability has been inactivated
and am i right that lobsters and crabs
can regrow claws
that's right okay yeah that's right yes
yet another very different set of
organisms
i mean once once you say that and again
i'm getting the feeling that i'm gonna
ask you a whole bunch of unfair
questions but i never know whether you
know the answers are known but you know
in physics we know a lot of things and
we know exactly what we don't know but
in biology uh there's so much we don't
know that we keep stumbling across
things so
uh
from an evolutionary point of view
why can't we just regrow limbs like that
would seem to be very useful
thing to be able to do if i lost a
finger or a hand just to regrow it you
know is there some
story we can tell about why most
organisms
don't regrow limbs why isn't that the
conventional usual story
right that's
a lot of biologists are also asking that
question because the ability to
regrow lost body parts seems to
it seems that it should be useful yeah i
would think
yeah
so the thinking the thing is there might
be a trade-off we don't know what the
trade-off is but perhaps the ability to
regenerate is coupled with some other
maladaptive
side effects but we don't know that so
but
the hope is that if we know
what governs
a latent ability to regenerate then we
can start speculating right so speaking
of speculating let's let's just do it
what what might be these trade-offs does
it cost too much energy or food maybe to
regenerate a whole limb
right
well i
i can say what i can speculate based on
what we find
right
um
but that will mean that i will have to
describe what we find please please
describe what you found now don't don't
hold back on my account
well like you said in in the jellies we
first found that they don't
typically grow lost appendages instead
they just
regain body symmetry
what
we subsequently found after long
uh three years of screening is that
under certain very specific conditions
they can
grow
loss appendages
and it's not always perfect
but the idea is that we can kick-start
latent a coke-slated ability to regroup
bandages to to emerge
and then
to quickly summarize and then i can
explain later is that
the the the same strategy
that we found worked in jellyfish
worked as well in
the fruit fly drosophila
in coaxing limb to regrow in fruit flies
and
finally in in in mouse
okay now we're talking right i mean
mice are pretty close
that's right that's right in the mice i
have to clarify that the mouse digit is
our model to
explore how to induce if we can induce
limb regeneration in humans
sure
so we have a situation where
is it
you said it's like under some
circumstances that these limbs do
regenerate versus just symmetrization or
something like a mouse doesn't even
symmetrize right like
we just sort of heal over the wounds or
whatever but but you said for the
jellyfish and presumably for the flies
and for the mice the conditions have to
be right so what do those conditions
have to be
right and um
that
was
part of the surprise of the finding is
that
first of all there's no guarantee that
we can induce
appendage or limb regeneration if you go
to animals that don't regenerate there's
never there's not a guarantee that that
the ability is there
so the first surprise is that the fact
that we could observe it at all
and the second surprise was the
conditions
the the conditions was uh surprisingly
simple
in jellies the factors that we needed to
present to them
to cooks appendage regeneration
are simple nutrient factors
one is just a very high amount of food
we think more than they normally see
and then the growth hormone insulin
and the amino acid leucine
the same factors also worked in flies we
just mixed the amino acid leucine and
the growth hormone insulin in their food
same thing in mice
we mixed
leucine and in the case of mice we can't
give insulin orally because just like in
humans insulin cannot be administered
orally it gets digested in our guts so
instead of insulin we just
give the mice sugar
okay
to induce endogenous production of
insulin so just
simple amino acid leucine and insulin
mixed in the drinking water and vegan
cooks
digit regrowth in about 20 of the mice
and these are again just for people who
know even less biology than me these
amino acids the insulin and the leucine
they're kind of universal like all life
forms make use of these already it's not
something that is specialized to these
organisms that's right humans
our bodies can make some amino acid and
we need some amino acids from our food
so leucine is one of those that we
intake from food it's called essential
amino acids
and actually leucine is something that
should be familiar to all of us because
if we have a friend that's into
bodybuilding leucine is one of the
supplements that they take to promote
muscle growth so yes it's
in us too the same processes
and maybe let's be very very specific
about what the results were because you
kind of alluded to them a little bit uh
both what percentage of the time did you
get limbs to regenerate and when they
did regenerate did they go all the way
or were they like stunted little
things what did it look like
right so it varies in different
organisms so i think in mice as i said
20
of them show regrowth
and the digit regrowth is of various
extent from
moderate regrowth to almost perfect
regrowth
right
but the most exciting thing is that it
it happens
[Laughter]
yes it's not full it's not complete all
the time but it happens and we have a
toe hold
so now the question is how can we make
them more perfect and stronger and now
is this the first example that you know
of of limb regeneration
other than species that do it
automatically that you know do you coax
them along to doing it
no so thank you sean for clarifying that
so so what's new about this
so people have studied
in some animals how
people have studied animals
and ask how to make them regenerate so
most of
studies of inducing regeneration
it's been done in
frogs okay
and also more recent studies in mouse
digits so in frogs for instance you know
it's like
it peaked this question of how to induce
regeneration peaked in early 20th
century
and then there was just this really
wonky discovery so people found all
kinds of things that could make frogs
regenerate so let me clarify first frogs
so why is frog an interesting system for
his nutrition system because as a
tadpole they can regrow limb
limbs
but then this ability is dramatically
lost upon
metamorphosis
so tadpoles can read grow limb and frogs
cannot so then the question is can you
reactivate regeneration that's been lost
upon metamorphosis so notice how
specific i'm phrasing the question yes
okay and then people found all sorts of
things electrical signals
can cook
limb regrowth in adult frogs
what else did you assault to simple salt
administration
and then
i think osmotic
shock as well just all kinds of
stimuli
right and the studies kind of peter off
because there
it didn't lead to
a lot of mechanistic insights okay so
it's not clear yeah
so these are frogs yeah but these are
all in species where
like you just said just to clarify they
already at one point in their
development had the ability to regrow
and so maybe you're more optimistic and
you you zapped them in the right way and
they the adult frog would regrow but it
wasn't you weren't able to sort of
generalize that to other species or
anything like that
exactly so i think that was that was the
key and that's why i
said earlier that i think we're at an
exciting place where
a general framework might be emerging
is it is it generally true that younger
organisms are better at regenerating or
things like regenerating than older ones
are
exactly so so it's like it's study so
it's like so i think i think you brought
up
different points and but you mentioned
earlier how
a lot of some animals that can
regenerate they don't all come from the
same lineages
so the opposite of that
let me rephrase that
so in fact
the more we study regeneration and in
particular in the past couple of decades
the more animals we study
and ask
which animals regenerate which animals
don't regenerate and what
is a striking insight
from studies in the past couple of
decades is that
one
like sean lucky said john that
animals that can regenerate don't all
come from evolutionarily close lineages
they're all scattered across the animal
phylogeny so that's one
and then
two is that in fact the more the closer
we look
at different animals more realized
actually
young animals crossed the young stages
across animal species have greater
regenerative capacity than the older
ones
like the embryos obviously have an
amazing ability to they have to generate
their whole body in the first place yes
exactly that's the embryos but then
newborns
tadpoles juvenile stages have greater
regenerative capacity than adults
right
yeah mice
for instance can newborn mice can reject
can we grow
injured hearts
but this ability is rapidly lost upon a
couple of days i think after birth
it does surprise me a little bit again i
mean
we all these animals can heal when they
get a wound right so there's there's
some decision i know this is too
anthropomorphic but it is some decision
that evolution made to
stop older animals from being able to
regenerate even though number one the
younger ones could and number two the
older ones can still heal uh minor or
major wounds that seems like there has
to be a reason why uh evolution prevents
us from doing this right and you keep
going you keep touching back to the
speculation which i will divert at the
very end before i speculate okay
but i'm going to add another a third
point to your uh to this um
the intriguing picture which is that
not only that all of us
have
capacity for what we call tissue repair
or maintaining tissue homeostasis we
our skin
cells completely rapidly turn over
continually turn over during lifetime we
can in
uh repair
minor
injuries to the bones to
muscles right so we have this baseline
ability
to replace cells
to
repair
inter minor injury to tissues
well i wanted to ask more about that
because again i'm not a biologist but uh
you we all know that cells can divide
right cells can grow a little bit and
divide um
but i usually when i'm told that story
think about unicellular organisms i
don't actually know that much about the
cells in my body are typical cells in my
body
dividing all the time and some of them
must be dying off otherwise i'd be
growing even faster than i am
um
it varies across organs
okay
yeah
if the
cells turn over in some organs faster
than others
and in some other organs maybe
very very slowly
but it's
it's pretty amazing because our skin
cells
for instance
um and
can you believe this okay
the cells that make up our skin are
replaced every two or three weeks
so that means you're a completely
different person
yeah
by the skin appearance or cell wise
every uh
few weeks or so
but so how does this happen because uh
is it that the skin cells divide or they
just die off and are replaced with stem
cells or something from somewhere else
right the point being that our body has
a baseline capacity to continually place
cells or to mend
mild injuries so the question is
since our young self
has greater capacity to regrow lost
parts
and even as a doll we continue to
maintain this
basal ability right
physiological ability
to replace cells and fix tissues
then how far can we push this
sure sure how far can we stretch this
ability
and i don't even know that much about
the process of healing wounds to be
honest is is that mostly a process where
you're
introducing new healthy cells to replace
the damaged ones or does the body
fix cells at a at that kind of level or
you know take cells and
sew them together in more functional
ways
it's a mix of both okay
yeah so a little bit of cells
replacement but also but primarily just
a
covering the wound yeah okay
re-epithelialization to cover the wound
with new cells
with new cells right yes okay good so i
mean sorry we got off track but let's go
back to the regeneration here with the
jellyfish so uh you mentioned that there
were a few factors that were important
to the regeneration the energy and the
amino acids um
but you didn't
need to give them electrical shocks or
anything like that like we picture the
frogs or frankenstein or whatever
shocking uh
organs or tissues um did you sort of go
through a whole bunch of different
things that you could try to do before
you honed in on the ones that actually
seem to be relevant
yes and i like to tell the stories
because
when you tell people that oh
the retention can be coaxed it seems so
easy after the fact but it was actually
really pretty hard
it's actually really really hard to find
the conditions that
could make yeah could make them
regenerate and so we spent
almost three years
to and just
screen through many many conditions
try as many molecules that we could get
a hold of to just
see what we can find we have
starting hypothesis of course we tested
processes that are often implicated in
studies of regeneration
of in for instance salamanders and uh
planarians anhydrous but
yeah we just tested everything that we
could think of
what we found yeah what we found was
something that we didn't expect and that
was i guess
what what makes science fun absolutely
do i remember correctly also i forget
whether you mentioned it but i think
remember reading that low oxygen levels
were was helpful
that's right that's another thing that
we haven't followed up i think we
focused so far in
in the
nutrient
factors
the inject and we tested
the nutrient factors in in flies and in
mice but we haven't followed up on the
hypoxia it's actually a very strong
effect of in uh regeneration
go ahead yeah
go ahead oh no please good it seems
weird to me because we don't know why
yeah okay we don't know why good i could
have guessed i mean that's why it's good
to get on the ground floor like i always
want to use this podcast to inspire
young students to uh
go follow up on these things um
it just seems weird to me because oxygen
is important uh for life for animal life
anyway but you know i guess if this kind
of capacity
does originate way back there in
evolutionary time maybe it comes from a
time when oxygen was less important or
even
yes that is actually a
good idea and i haven't thought much
about that connection honestly
and i will now okay good
[Laughter]
but what we do know
from the three factors that promote that
we found so far that uh that promote
regeneration in the jellyfish and this
includes uh
reduced oxygen levels is that they all
promote growth
okay
yeah
much faster under these conditions
right and and the bodybuilders like this
leucine so there's something about
the
regeneration of a limb which is
basically supercharged growth of the
organism right
exactly
so we don't know yet whether it's a
parallel or whether it has some causal
connections a coincidence that two
conditions are related
and then so it makes me wonder and again
i'm going to speculate and don't worry
about giving away secrets that they're
going to appear later on but
growth has its ups and downs right i
mean cancer is the kind of growth that
can get in the way and and maybe the
reason why evolution shuts off our
ability to regenerate limbs is because
keeping it on would open us up to other
vulnerabilities like getting cancer too
easily
exactly so i think i think you're nicely
leading us to
making the circulation
please speculate away
yeah so i think i think that's
well
so
that's what i meant earlier is like the
more we know about the process the more
we're able to form a hypothesis a
responsible hypothesis as to why
animals
not all animals
regenerate and in this case based on
what we find that
simple nutrient factors the high amount
of nutrient factors can coax latent
regeneration to
emerge suggests that
yes it might be some energetic trade-off
right so perhaps
the uh
conditions that we require that is
required for which
that is permissive for regeneration is
also a condition that is
permissive for cancer development for
instance right of course we don't know
this for sure but we can start thinking
making hypothesis along this direction
and i mean certainly we can imagine
there's good evolutionary reasons why
you and i
stop growing at a certain age right like
we just linearly growed and grew in size
that would be bad we'd soon our
metabolic needs would get too large so
there could there be some kind of side
effect thing going on where
the
evolution wants us to stop growing and
that process also stops us from being
able to regenerate
right right that's a very good point so
a couple of things so before before i
get to that i should mention that yes
the speculations have been made we're
not the first one speculating that
regeneration has a tradeoff with cancers
but i think that what we're finding
allows us to anchor that
with
following up that hypothesis with
perhaps identifying specific pathways
where the trade-off might occur so
that's right so that's what makes me
excited about ah okay this is long what
people have thought about but now we can
get specific pathways and the other
thing that you said is just true is
might not just be side effect but it
also because of the way we grow
when we grow we stop growing
our metabolic
our metabolic state actually changes
from utilizing specific pathways that
are focused on making
materials building blocks
for making new cells new tissues we
switch to a different pathway
that allows us to make energy more
efficiently
so then one question is like is that
switch
might that have something to do with
decrease in our ability to regenerate
could you go into a little bit more
details about that the audience likes a
little bit of details what are these two
different ways of generating energy
we're thinking of right so
um
so in in one
metabolic
pathway that's more associated with
growing state we utilize we break down
food
we utilize
carbohydrates using this pathway called
glycolysis and this
is a pathway that is intriguingly is
also heavily utilized by cancer cells
okay all right yes
and then as we grow we switch from
glycolysis heavy to
another pathway of breaking down carbs
that utilizes what's called the
oxidative phosphorylation
and this pathway is a lot more effective
in making energy from
every molecule of glucose
so it really is the difference between
way of processing food that's focused on
making
building blocks
versus way of processing food that's
focused on thriving
energy
and for something like a human being
when does this transition happen
oh that's a good point i don't know the
exact transition point
but whether it's correct
three weeks or 18 years or 50 years
well we're still growing as a teenager
right okay
so my guess is gradually
switching switching i also don't know
whether how much this has been
characterized okay
in in quantitative way
i mean
both this and other podcasts i've done
on biology really drive home the fact
that
you know we're not intelligently
designed we we organisms we human beings
right like it's a it's a constant set of
trade-offs between this and that and
when you say well why can't i do this
there's always a reason why well that
would lead to this bad effect somewhere
else
yes i i like that idea i like that that
point that you're making it
let me get a little bit more detailed
about the
what we see when we see these limbs
regenerating uh i mean
is it like
literally slow growth of layers of cells
lying on top of each other just or how
similar is it to
a baby growing right i mean or is it a
completely different kind of thing or is
it just you're remembering your
jellyfish or your fly is remembering
what it was like to grow that limb in
the first place
right right right so it is like
if you look at it i mean if you look at
it morphologically it is like
regrowing growing a limb
so that's why a lot of people often
think of regeneration as recapitulation
of development
i did have a did do a podcast with
michael levin i don't know if you know
him from tufts oh yes yes and i'm a big
fan of his yeah he has wonderful ideas
about how like the organism kind of
knows what shape it wants to be and and
sort of
moves its face uh in the right direction
and that i guess that's a trade-off
because when you say
i'm making this up and michael's not
here to correct me but when you say the
organism knows what it wants to be
does it want to be symmetric like that
that's a fact that the jellyfish had and
they sort of fixed that when they lost a
limb just by rearranging the other ones
or does it want to have eight limbs in
which case you know you want to
regenerate so there's sort of different
ways to fulfill that goal of being what
you want to be
right and i'm going to speculate even
more
which is that well
first of all it's
it's still a question how we know the
[ __ ] that will eventually become yeah
right and
in regeneration specifically i think
it's a different end of
like the spectrum of questions is
there's
how to kick-start regeneration right
which is what we're interested in i
think michael michael is also interested
in that as well in his work in frogs
and then uh
and then how does it know when to stop
because if you don't know
right
which is this question is like
it knows the [ __ ] that it was but how
does it know how does it know because if
you don't know how to stop then you have
uncontrolled growth
and that is of course
cancer
yeah no i mean actually that's a very
good way to put it you're clarifying it
to me because i feel you know a little
bit insulted that my body isn't smart
enough to regrow a limb if i lose it but
on the other hand i don't want my
existing limbs to just grow to be 20
feet long right i want them to grow to
the right length and then stop and so
it's not that hard to imagine that the
same thing that stops my actual arms
from growing stops me from growing new
ones when i lose this one yeah
yes exactly and i think that question of
how does
how does the organism know the shape
that it wants to be or does it want to
be in a certain shape to begin with
that is a that is a fascinating question
in itself that's a big picture question
yes i mean maybe we can get more clues
so we have the jellyfish and then but
the flies and the mice
somehow
this is my human parochialism it seems
more astonishing to me that you can get
them to regrow limbs uh jellyfish is
like it's jelly like how hard can it be
but the uh
is it is the thing that regrows on the
uh flies and the mice are they just as
functional or is it like a stunted
little thing
right right right so
first of all yes we tend to think that
humans are more complex than other
animals
we're going to
and but that there's
a lot of us often like to post these
questions it's like oh how how true is
that statement are we really that much
more complex than a bacterium for
instance bacteria are pretty fascinating
too and can like we know
some of them can append our whole lives
um but yes so to answer your question is
it functional in jelly so we can make a
movies and we can show that yes they can
pull synchronously the new
appendages paul synchronously with the
uh the existing arms
uh same thing in flies too we can make
little videos and we know that they walk
okay with a little imperfect limb that
they're regrowing so in fact we're
considering uh some we're trying to test
whether the walking is necessary to
cooks
further regrowth so that's
the use using it stimulates it's just
like
our muscles
how we lose them from this use for
instance yeah and in the audience you
don't know but leah is mimicking a fly
walking around so just imagine in your
head little fly squirming around
yes
and in mice um
we haven't done we're still trying to
we've done bone staining the way we
assess regrowth in mice not only by
taking photograph of the digit we can
see that the nail uh tissues is uh are
regrown but we also can stain the bones
and we should we can show that here's
where the amputation is and there's new
growth
new bones being grown from the
amputation plane
and then we're still trying to think of
a design maybe a climbing design where
you can tell
how well they use the new uh the new
digit segment that's regrown so that's
so part of the fun distance if a
non-biologist such as myself were to see
one of your flies that had regrown a
limb would i be able to tell that it had
regrown a limb or would it look just
like a regular fly
yes and no one is that because it's not
perfect so you know that that leg has
been amputated in fact that fly is
really challenging for us because we
have not been able to
fully
uh regret the limit in my swift it's
actually more dramatic advice than
implies but it's very dramatic to in in
slice in the sense that
it is uh partial still but it's
multi-segments so we can grow multiple
segments of the lakes
or we indians in the sense that the
flies can grow the flies
this is part of the wonderful thing here
is that you're not training it you're
just putting in the right situation it
knows what it wants to do right
yes yes yes i think it's like
like
that's a good point
in the sense that
when
when we all started this is
a lot of talented students are involved
in this project
um
also courageous because i told them that
hey
yeah let's try this
and like i said there is no guarantee
that it could happen and the way we
currently imagine of how we will
eventually cook slim regeneration in
humans some people dare to imagine like
he said it almost sounds like science
fiction but the way we currently imagine
that is that we're going to have to
mimic development reconstitute
development
give a certain specific signals at
different times specific combinations of
signals maybe
form a gradient so it's
really controlling the dose the timing
the different types of molecules that
are administered at different times
combined with some biophysical stimuli
perhaps electrical as well as mechanical
stimuli so it's very complex process
that we're imagining
so part of the surprise here is that ah
first of all the lathe and the building
is there
and it's a simple tilt
can
start can cooks the process to start so
that that brings just
a little bit more hope
to perhaps
so that that process that you just that
sort of complicated procedure you just
outlined is you're saying that's what we
might have guessed
would be required but in fact the body
knows what limb it's supposed to have
and it's more a matter of coaxing it to
take advantage not take advantage even
but to realize that uh goal that it's
had all along and the body will figure
out what to do at what stage in the
process
yes that's what i'm optimistic
optimistic
[Laughter]
but you know how we can speculate here
it's late in the podcast you know how
close
are we i mean it might seem pretty close
and he's you said that the mice did it a
little bit better
than even the flies did um
i mean what what are the steps in
between here and
getting to people
oh
that's
that's always something that you one has
to be your father just has to be really
cautious about
i won't tell anyone
but i think the optimism serves
just to motivate the experiments that we
do the experiments are all right so
that's once
in defense of optimism
but i think it will take
a lot of efforts a lot of courageous
students
uh you know i want to emphasize right
now our model is the mouse digit right
one finger yeah
one thing at a time
and it's a digit because it's a gentler
amputation so we don't want to without
stronger hypothesis we don't want to
start experimenting on limb directly
right
but
that's the hope is that now what we have
is like i said a tool hold into the
problem
and
now we can start understanding the
mechanisms
if we understand the mechanisms then we
can engineer it to be better
that's the hope
and
if we're lucky then
maybe we can make
leaps ahead right but i mean what so but
what would the steps be we're we're i'm
not saying that they're going to be
possible they might not work it might
never happen for human beings i see if
you get better at the mice do we then
move on to chimps or uh is it
some intermediate stage where it's like
half prosthesis and half growing a
little bit i don't know what what do you
imagine if we're not none of this is
real so we're not we're not under the
any obligation to predict correctly
right
so i think a couple of things
one is that lim
in some way is
is a great model because ironically it's
uh the procedure to test it is
simpler than let's say resecting an
organ
and also the outcome is extreme and
clear so that's
why we start with the limb right it's
ironically it's simpler
to assess
so how do how do i envision getting
there if we can get there is that one is
that at the moment there are several uh
time skills here at the moment
lim like i said it's simpler but also
it's a great model because being able to
regrow limb a limb
uh
represents the complex challenge of
regrowing a
complex organ so it needs
uh generating news many new cells
patterning the cells in space and time
and then
building tissues
from the new cells so it's uh
but a limb has multiple tissues so if
you know how to redraw them we know how
to enhance regrowth of muscle
bone
joint
etc so all those can already have
optimistically speaking perhaps
usefulness so in the intermediate scale
maybe we're not regrowing a full limb
but what we learned from regrowing a
limb can help us
with enhancing the regeneration of
multiple tissues
and then like you said well if we want
to know the mechanism because then we
can approach this in a more
um
rational design
manner
that's the dream in biology it's like to
make it more like physics where it's
more theory driven rather than
observation driven where we are right
now
and then once we have that
the ability to predict
right so ideally we would have a
mathematical model coupled with
mechanistic understanding of the process
then
i think that would
feel empowered that would be empowering
to go to
right
the more
yeah
different we have to test it in two or
three more species before
yeah humans but but you're raising a
very good point which i would have
figured out if i were a biologist which
is that you know of course our
imaginations go to something dramatic
like regrowing a limb to someone who's
lost a limb but there's
a lot of potential cases where
there are
wounded or damaged or dying organs in
our bodies or something like that
and that might eventually be an even
sooner
realistic
use for this kind of process yeah
yes that's right so what we're studying
now is that
every every contribution is it's just i
think it's just a very exciting uh field
the field of regenerative medicine
and it's also basic biology-wise it's
like it's amazing of how much we can
push our body to do
but like like he said um
i i also want
another thing that i find really
exciting is the fact that all right so
our essay is the limb but then we
administer
leucine or insulin or sugar
through diet
the animals eat them okay
that's pretty easy pretty simple
pretty simple in a way
um
and then so the idea is like it's
systemic
the factors
are all over are just systemically the
effect so far that we have essayed is
very specific the limb but then the
question that i'm excited about is like
well actually
how systemic is the effect
[Laughter]
generally
no i mean that's a very very good point
so now i'm thinking about it so because
it's a different visualization when it's
a jellyfish versus a mouse so for this
mouse it's regrowing a digit
but the things you're doing to it you're
doing to its whole body
and so on the one hand you worry or
maybe you're hopeful that it's fixing
everything in its body or doing just
growing in crazy ways but on the other
hand
is it it seems to be smart enough to
know where the lost digit is and
concentrate its efforts on growing that
back is that right exactly that's right
so on
on practical level if you think of
translation it's worrying because well
you don't want to
affect the whole body so maybe you will
have to design something more specific
but
anthology-wise it's like it's
fascinating that you tweak the whole
body
and yet it knows specifically to
yeah repairs i mean i think overall
again i'm not constrained by the
standards or ethics of being a biologist
so it seems very optimistic to me what
you're saying is that the body has
enormous latent capacity to fix itself
as long as we give it the right raw
ingredients so we don't need to go in
there with a scalpel and a micrometer or
whatever and carefully fix it cell by
cell just give it food and stand back
and the body will fix itself
yes that's actually a very good way
of yes of of of
saying what we found optimistic
i
i think that
it's not optimistic i think that it's
it's really is what we're seeing along
with what the field is also other
studies in the field are beginning to
see as well
so it's i think that's just an amazing
insight in my mind that
and especially that the same thing works
across multiple species which means that
if you look out your windows just what
whatever animals you're seeing the birds
the squirrels beetles ah we all have
this amazing ability to repair our body
we grow a limb
or any body parts you just need a little
tilt too
and and
this relates to something that we were
hinting at before maybe you've already
said it out loud but
the the potential existence of some kind
of ancestral ability here some something
that arose this ability arose
way back when in the evolutionary tree
like maybe
when multicellularity arose right when
we first started differentiating
organs of our body in the first place
right that's right
so
right like i yeah so we discussed
earlier that there's these two different
differing opinions among historically
more biologists that some feel that or
think that
the ability to regenerate is something
adaptive so you evolve it specifically
for a specific body parts like
right
but then some other biologists think
that it's
something inherent in all of us
just like a cell dividing is something
inherent that a cell
does
so
we don't know which one is right but if
all animals have it then
it raises the possibility that it's
something ancestral
in animals and if it's something
ancestral maybe it's really tied into
the very basic property of biological
cells
right right i'm going to show my
ignorance once again but
plants and animals seem very different
in this way i mean to me when i look at
a tree with all of its branches
i don't think
that the specific locations of all those
branches were built into its dna right
there were some accidents of history
that made that happen whereas when i
look at a person with two arms and two
legs i think that was built into the dna
am i am i right or wrong to think that
plants are sort of more plastic in this
way and animals are a little bit more
rigid in their design
right uh
yes i think so because the functions the
shape of an animal is more the way i
think about it is more closely tied to
the functions yeah more differentiated
exactly yeah or like specific shapes of
animals that's right but
high deep regulation between growth
and
repair could be conserved at that
level that makes sense
i guess another as we're winding down
here another big
potential implication for this i mean we
started with regeneration which is
already pretty big but you know other
regenerative healing is is fascinating
um
there's a whole bunch of other things
that go wrong with our bodies like uh
alzheimer's disease or just aging in
general
these are also situations where
our our bodies our brains sort of know
what they're supposed to do and kind of
give up in some way they're like yeah
we've done this for long enough we've
outlived our reproductive usefulness you
know we don't need to keep it up
do these new techniques or technologies
potentially open a way to
uh extend our lifespans or our
alertness lifespans
that's the hope
that's the hope it is a
very active field aging and
neurodegenerative diseases it's hard to
uh speculate responsibly
in that direction
but
i think that
i think the broader hope of regenerative
medicine is
exactly that which is that if we can
right maintain our tissues and working
conditions
and
fix our brains or something goes wrong
then we can improve our lifespan it can
improve our life quality
i should mention there's also a
trade-off speculated between lifespan
and regenerative capacities and cancer
so that's
a whole
new discussions
but
i wonder sometimes whether these
processes are tied in and so the big
challenge is
to identify the specific
processes
that
that's right that's right
and part of the good news that you have
is that
again we've said this already but it's
so so amazing to me let's repeat it that
you're not in there micro planning cell
by cell you're just giving some
resources to the body so
the ideal utopian future for combating
aging or neurodegeneration is
take the right pills or the right shots
right or eat the right food and let the
body do it itself that's the crazy
utopian hope right
that's right that's right and like you
said take the right pills that means pre
and free are you thinking about
preemptive regenerative treatment even
before the injury even happens we can
prepare the body right and the potential
downside not to end on a down note but
the potential downside is making it much
more likely that we get cancer or are
subject to some other catastrophic
failure because it's like supercharging
the engine of a car right like it goes
faster but it might blow up
exactly that's right so
from application side of you this is
still a long path ahead but from basic
biology
point of view it's fascinating that it
ties in to all these different processes
for instance sugar sugar obviously
promotes diabetes
and wound healing is disrupted in
diabetic state
so then what is the connection between
these two this different
right sure
let me end with just a little bit of a
meta uh discussion i mean uh i know that
i'm at caltech but it's a complicated
place what what is what department are
you in at caltech what kind of biology
what is the label we put on for this
kind of thing
ah
well
uh
i'm in division of biology and
biological engineering and that's all of
us doing research in different
uh
questions in biology so we're all just
one division
okay yeah i know caltech is weird so the
big divisions but then smaller
departments within the division like i'm
in physics math and astronomy but
physics within that
yes and it's i think it's structured a
little differently in biology
i mean i'm thinking
who want to you know do this kind of
thing if they're looking at different
places to apply like what what is the
kind of biology that this is
i see um
it's
regeneration biology would be the field
that i associate but there's
but then we asked also evolutionary
questions
and
we're also approaching it somewhat in
and from engineering point of view
make something happen yes that's right
so bioengineering is another uh
um
part a sub
uh department that i associate with but
it really is a lot more amorphous than
that
it is and you know caltech doesn't have
a medical school either but probably
some other places do if people are
really interested in the uh potential
therapeutic applications of this down
the road
right yes although if i were to position
myself i think we're still more in the
basic basically research side of things
that's the fun side of things to be on i
think that's a perfectly good place
all right it's extremely exciting i i
you know i once had a friend of mine
who's a biologist tell me that uh we're
in the last generation of people who
might die
of old age and someday we'll figure it
all out
see i think i'm pretty optimistic but
that's still a little too optimistic for
me i i certainly hope it's true it will
never be too optimistic
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast this was great thank
you again sean
[Music]
you